Another form of oracle comes in the form of enhanced execution environments.
I've already used the example several times,
but in C or C++ we could run the compiled program under a runtime monitor like Valgrind
which provides an enhanced execution environment which checks a lot of rules
that aren't checked by the regular C and C++ runtime or by the operating system.
So for example, Valgrind will terminate our process
if we access beyond the end of an array,
and in practice, that's an extremely effective form of oracle.
If that kind of a rule violation happens during random testing,
we absolutely want to know about it, and Valgrind provides that service.
Another example of an enhanced execution environment
would be one that checks for, for example, integer overflow of problems
or floating point problems.
So a medium oracle is going to vary in its degree of checking power
between the weak oracles we've already said
and the strong oracles that I'll talk about in a few minutes.
And so far in my list, and I could be missing something,
but so far I only have one example of a medium power oracle,
and this is assertion checks that the programmer has put into the software.
The reason I call this a medium power oracle
is it provides quite a lot more application-specific
kind of checking than do these weak oracles.
But on the other hand, it doesn't guarantee anything
even remotely close to actual correct operation,
and that's generally what the strong oracles are going to do.
So let's look at those.